and you see string theory is a
multiverse theory so people say first of
all what is string theory yes string
theory simply says that all the
particles we see in nature the electron
the proton the quarks what have you or
nothing with vibrations on a musical
string on a tiny tiny little string you
know gee Robert Oppenheimer the creator
of the atomic bomb was so frustrated in
the 1950s with all these subatomic
particles being created in our atom
smashers
that he announced he announced one day
that the Nobel Prize in Physics she'd go
to the physicist who does not discover a
new particle that year well today we
think they're nothing but musical notes
on these tiny little vibrating strings
so what is physics physics is the
harmonies you can write on vibrating
strings
what is chemistry chemistry is the
melodies you can play on these strings
what is the universe the universe is a
symphony of strings and then what is the
mind of God that Albert Einstein so
eloquently wrote about for the last
thirty years of his life the mind of God
would be cosmic music resonating through
eleven dimensional hyperspace
you